- [Mark] All right. Adrian.
- Hey.
- [Mark] Adrian, where did you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- Uh, I was born in East LA, grew up in
the City of Commerce.
Went to Bollards High.
Got into some trouble
in my senior year and I
finished off in Montabello.
Got a full-ride to Cal
State LA. I was a poulterer,
and I ...
just drugs and alcohol. Yeah.
- [Mark] What age were
you when you first got ...
- I'm sorry?
- [Mark] What age were
you when you first got
involved with drugs?
- When I first got ... when I first drank,
I was nine years old. And when
I first started smoking pot,
I was about 15.
- [Mark] Wow.
- Yeah. And then after
that, it just kind of
just lead to more and more.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family.
You grew up with two parents?
- No.
My mom. I grew up with my
mom. A very strong woman.
Middle ... I was the middle child. She ...
My eldest brother was the golden boy
and my younger son was
autistic; so I bore the brunt
of everything her mom did to her.
And she was an alcoholic
as well, and she would ...
she would beat me.
And she would ... she
would sexually abuse me.
And when ...
- [Mark] How old were you?
- When she'd do that? I
didn't stop sleeping in the
same bed with her until I was 12.
- [Mark] Oh, wow.
- And I ... and that's when
I went to go stay with my
brother in Spain. He was in
the Air Force, and then his ...
his wife seduced me, and I
got ... and that happened.
It's ... it's been pretty
much no stability in
my entire life. I ...
it just didn't pan out.
I ... I was a cutter.
I ... I just stopped
cutting last year. But,
that was another way to deal
with ... with everything.
And yeah. It just ...
you know, I've been married
four times; all abusive women.
I have two boys.
My older son's 29;
and my younger son is 26.
My older son's an animator.
He works for the Studios
in Burbank. He does his runs.
And my younger son is a
chef. For the life of me,
I can't remember the
name of the restaurant,
but it's here in Downtown LA.
- [Mark] So you're kids are great.
- Yes. I was completely
transparent with them from
the get-go. And I pretty much said, if ...
my older son ... I groomed
him to be an animator.
I mean, I ... I always wanted
to be one, but I couldn't
get it together. I had no discipline.
So that's all he ever wanted to do.
And when he started to, you
know ... what's the word
I'm looking for? When he
started to test drugs or
experiment, I told him,
"You have to make a choice.
Either you're going to give
your life over to the drugs,
and, you know, just be like your old man.
Or be an animator. You
can't ... there's no ...
there's no mixing the two."
And my younger son as well.
He's ... he's also a writer.
He ... he would take his
skateboard down to Venice Beach,
and set up his old typewriter
and sell poems, or sonnets,
or laundry lists for $2 a pop. He ...
his fiance met him there,
took a picture of him,
put it on the internet, and it went viral.
And he still gets commissions
from, you know, like
Spain and France for just poems. He's ...
He's published two ...
two poetry books already;
self-financed.
And it's been ...
it's been tough because
they went from dad being
this hero to then seeing
the sad truth of ... of
with ... you know, the
alcoholic drug addict.
And now it's kind of a ...
They don't ... you know I'm
... I'm sometimes treated
with the like a ... like
a stray dog. You know?
Just like, "Yeah. He's there and stuff."
But I've been trying
to ... I ... I actually
started AA a couple of ... a month ago ...
a little bit over a month ago.
I fell off the wagon,
and I was bartending,
and it was really just
... you know, and they ...
They kind of hinted to me
that, "Oh, hey," you know,
"it's no drinking on the
job," you know, so I ...
and yesterday when I went into work,
before I started they sat me down
and ... and they said, you
know, "You're a great guy
and everything but, you
have a drinking problem."
And I was like, "Well, I know
that." You know, "I'm ..."
And then my girl ...
I just bailed; and I've been
down here since yesterday.
- [Mark] On Skid Row?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Mark] And so, it's ...
it's alcohol and crack
that are your ...
- Well, alcohol triggers everything.
You know, it's ... it's the
... it's the thing that I
can go get at the store ...
- [Mark] Yeah.
- ... that's readily available.
- [Mark] It's everywhere.
- Everywhere. And as soon as
I get enough in me, (snap)
before you know it, I'm
down at ... on Gladys.
You know, "Oh. Hey Adrian."
- [Mark] Where you can get anything.
- Yeah. And, you know, it ...
it ...
it doesn't ... I want
to say it doesn't work
for me anymore because it I
... it never worked for me,
but it was always something
that I could count on.
You know, I don't really have any friends.
Or the closest thing to
a family that I've had is
my gal and her two kids.
And I ... you know, it's
almost like I don't ...
I can't accept the good. You know?
And I've worked on it. I
mean, I've seen a lot of
therapists and stuff, but
it just ... it doesn't seem
to ... you know, and I was
doing really good there for
a couple of weeks. And,
you know, I was feeling ...
I was looking really bad. I
mean, I had ... I had been
on a bender for a couple of
months where I was waking up
and drinking, and I was
going through two 750s of
Smirnoff a day. And then
at ... drinking at work,
and you know, I ... I guess
it showed more than I thought
it did. But it wasn't
until recently that they
brought it to my attention.
- [Mark] That what?
- They they had ... that they
brought it to my attention.
- [Mark] Okay.
- They brought it to my
attention two weeks ago
on a Sunday. And they're like,
"Well," you know, "you're ...
they pretty much said, "We're
going to let this one slide,
and ..." you know, and
even with that, I ... I ...
I still drank. I still drank at work.
And you know, my girl
didn't know I was drinking.
You know, I was smoking
weed and drinking Vodka
on the way to work,
and showing up to work,
and doing my job, and drinking
at work, and you know,
stopping the drink well ...
with enough time so that
when I'd get home I didn't smell.
And yeah. This ... I'd
like to say it's a new low,
but it's not. You know, it's ...
the only people that have ever really been
effected by my drinking has
been my girl and my boys.
And that's it. Everybody else pretty much,
you know, didn't ... I
wasn't important enough to
even say anything about
it, except when I would get
sloppy, and knock shit over, you know,
then I'd get yelled
at. But I, you know ...
I had a ... I got hired as
... as a house band at a
coffee shop in Sherman
Oaks, right down the street
from Casa Vega. And today was
going to be my first show.
And I'm here. And I ... I
don't know ... I don't know
what's going to happen next. You know,
I ... I had saved $1,200 to
get me into an apartment,
and then brought it, and
left it here pretty much
over the course of the
evening. Yeah. And ...
- [Mark] What do you
think ... I mean, is there
a history of addiction in your family?
- Alcoholism.
- [Mark] Alcohol?
- Yeah. Alcoholism. I'm not
sure if there was other stuff,
but my uncle died of perosis.
Drank to the day he died.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I know he did coke too.
But when my mom drank ...
my mom drank well into
... well into I was like
half way through high school.
And then she just stopped.
You know?
But yeah, as far as alcoholism, there is.
There's ... there's
addiction in my family.
My grandmother smoked.
My grandmother smoked two
packs of 100 Moors Menthals
every day and drank a
six-pack of Coca-Cola every day.
She lived to be 98, and
she was bit by a cat,
and the infection killed her.
- [Mark] Hm.
- Yeah. But she was ...
you know, she lived in
Sinaloa, Guasave, which
is a very ... you know,
the only paved ... paved
roads you would see would
be like in the middle of town;
and everything else is just dirt.
She lived across the street
from the graveyard that
had no wall around it. So
that's it. It was just very ...
so she'd be out there
every day, you know ...
you know, harvesting
eggs, killing chickens,
and you know, doing farm work.
And she was, you know ...
but I've ... I've been
... I've been able to be a
functional addict pretty
much my whole life.
And I used to think that
was a really cool thing;
and now it's ... it's terrifying because,
obviously I'm not a functional
addict because I'm here now.
I guess after a certain amount of time ...
and I'm almost 50, you know, and
I haven't done anything.
You know, I've written a lot,
and I've got 20 songs that I've written
that they're great songs.
All about drugs and alcohol. And ...
but as cautionary tales though.
You know, I never glorified
it. You know, I was never
one of those people that
... I mostly drank by myself
and do drugs by myself.
When I was ... when I was
in a band in the '90s,
there was that whole party
scene, you know, and the
guitar player's wife had
divorced and left him a
million-dollar home in Chino Hills.
And it was a great time. But even then,
I mean, I would get home
from a show and, you know,
everybody would be, "Hey."
You know, all the chicks.
You know, I was a singer,
so all the chicks wanted to
get at me. I'd go
upstairs and do my drugs,
and lock the door, and watch pornography,
and write, and draw. And, you know,
accused of being not male, you know,
because I didn't ... I don't know.
Sex to me is kind of a
... it's a strange thing.
You know, I ... up until
now with, you know ...
I was a male escort in my 20s.
And that was pretty much the same.
You know, and it was when I was with the
boys' mom; and she was
all for it because it's
like a lot of money. And ...
but there's always been this
thing about sex with
me that ... that's ...
not that it's ugly, but it's
not ... I don't have the ...
I enjoy sex and I ... you
know, when I was a kid,
I was introduced to
pornography very early on.
And that was where I
would find the closeness.
You know, watching people having sex,
that's where I find intimacy.
And I think I carried that
out until just recently
with, you know, the girl that
I'm ... she's my best friend.
I don't even want to
call her my girlfriend.
I've been able to really
let go of some of that.
You know, but it's still ...
- [Mark] Do you think those
experiences you had with ...
- It definitely damaged me. Yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Because my dad ...
it's funny. My mom, she is a guendalina,
which is like ... I don't
know if you've ever heard
of like santteria. And it comes
from my grandfather's side.
They ... you know, they were
all ... they all dabbled in
witchcraft and all of this and that;
but she was ... she is
a healer, and still is,
and my dad ... I met him when I was 21,
and he's a pastor, and
didn't like me one bit
because he said I was too opinionated
and I asked too many questions.
He actually called me a benigna.
- [Mark] Really?
- And he died last year.
And you know, I met my
whole another side of the family
through ... you know, my half brothers
and sisters and stuff,
and they're like, "Oh."
You know, and I'm like,
"I don't ... I don't feel anything."
You know, I didn't feel anything for him.
I met him ... I met him
like a handful of times from
21 until last year. And you know, I'm ...
they're like, "Oh. You've
got to come and party.
We're going to celebrate his life."
And I'm like, "What am I going to say?
I don't have any cool stories about him."
You know, I don't even have much to say.
You know, so I made my peace,
and they've ... you know,
I don't wish them ... I
never wished him ... I never
wished him any ill-will.
I was very angry, though,
for a long time as well as with my mom.
But then I learned to
release that. I buried them
because it turns out I was
doing their job for them
even after they were, you
know, weren't around anymore.
I was still abusing myself for them.
And yeah. So I mean, I've
made some progress in my life.
I've very ... I'm very
self-observant, and you know,
I don't lie. You know, I ...
every therapist I ever went to,
they're like, "Wow,"
you know, "it would have
taken us like three months
to get to what we got to
in this first session."
And I'm like, "Well, I
genuinely want to get better.
So the quicker I tell you
everything, the quicker
(snap) we can get down to
business." But eventually,
it would be a thing
where they would kind of
peter out because I just ...
the answers they were
giving me weren't enough.
Although I did learn
that ... that I wasn't
possessed by demons. I just
had a chemical imbalance,
because growing up, my
mom would tell me ...
Because I have ... I'm manic and bi-polar,
and I've even diagnosed
as borderline personality,
and a little autism.
But I got to tell you, man,
it was a relief to ...
to find out that ...
that there was just something
here that I could figure
out and fix, and that it
wasn't something, you know,
from another world that was
scary and waiting for me
under the bed.
But yeah.
I'm very spiritual. You know, I'm very ...
I'm ... I'm a very ... I've
been referred to in my life
as a sweet man. You know,
I'm very kind, I'm very
generous, and I ... I give
everything that I wasn't given
growing up, or that I
didn't get in any part
of my life. So ... as a
matter of fact, my children,
they ... they ... I never
yelled at them and they
never knew a heavy hand from me. Ever.
Even when they were
tiny. You know it's like,
"No way. The chain stops here."
Because my mom was abused,
and her mom was abused,
and so on, and so forth. So
that's one thing that I can
say that I've done in this
life is that they've ...
they ... they were raised without and ...
With logic, and it would be like ...
you know, even when they
were tiny, and there was no
verbal communication, you
know, there was just that ...
if I wasn't freaking out,
they weren't freaking out.
There was some ... you know, it ... it ...
to design (inaudible) taught us there that
language is third on the
list of communication.
You know, it's images, and
then music, and then ...
and then language. Because
you can go anywhere in the
world and know which
bathroom is men's and which
one's women. You know? And
you know, everybody loves
great music, even if they
don't understand the words.
So I've always kind of
worked from that place.
But right now, I'm ... I'm
... I really wish I had the
balls ... oh. I take that back.
I really wish that I had
a suicidal personality
so I can just be done. But I ...
I've always had a strong
relationship with God.
And I ... I can't be the
one to be, "Oh. I'm done."
I don't know what I'm meant
for or what. I'm still here.
I mean, I should be dead
thousands of times over,
and I'm not, and even
though I would want to just
shut it off. You know, there's ...
as I get older, it gets a
little stronger, but I can't ...
I can't ... I know I couldn't.
It's not in me. You know,
it's like I ... I couldn't ...
I haven't done anything yet. You know?
All ... all I can say is
that I've been a drug addict
and alcohol ... you know, and alcoholic.
And that's not much to
be left on the attack.
You know, I want ... I
want to be there more.
And yeah. That's all.
- [Mark] Adrian, thank you so
much for sharing your story.
- You're welcome.
- [Mark] I think the fact
that you raised your kids,
and they're walking a straight path
is a great accomplishment.
- Yeah. It is, but I want
something for me too.
- [Mark] Yeah. That's ...
- You know, I want ...
- [Mark] Important too. But ...
- Whereas I never thought
that I deserved it not up
until like a few years ago
where I sort of, you know,
actually ...
- [Mark] I think believing
you deserve it is a really
key part of ...
- Yes.
- [Mark] ... the whole process.
- Yes. And my ...
- [Mark] It's the most
important part, I think.
- My girl is the one that
started introducing me to
that kind of thought process.
- [Mark] I've talked to
a thousand people now,
and what I see, what I hear
over, and over, and over,
and over is, "I don't deserve
it. I don't deserve it.
I belong here. I'm worthless."
To change that way of
thinking, which is not easy ...
- No.
- [Mark] I think is the key.
- Yeah. But ... and that's
... that's all I knew
forever until about, you
know, four years ago when I
started down that path. You
know? And that's why I ...
- [Mark] I think that ...
I think that's the key.
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- [Mark] Excellent. Well,
thank you very much.
- Absolutely.